[Music]
is
back
he
take it
[Music]
off that's why I'm attacking
one see how I stick
back
right there
you so when I turn around here my idea
is to get you down
the
that that's the whole point of
okay so my objective is always contr you
out the whole time I'm thinking how do I
get
him just
did
so don't walk me don't float me here and
now I'm going to let you up you see and
now I'm going to walk you
out
see here
throw once you unwind it you have no
control anymore so you have to roll
around his
hand you see how I do that okay so I'm
here I use this as a forr I'll
show I use this hand to push see when I
push the elbow I I already have the Nel
bent of the final pin okay and that's
what allows this knee to drop to go
around it because if I do a straight arm
I end up picking up his shoulder
okay so I need to bend to push down for
you guys see that okay so I got to bend
the arm with the elbow hand I'm rolling
it and then this hand rides up to the
fingers and you already have Nik there
okay and now I replace it by putting his
knife edge in the fold of my
elbow and so now I can push down on that
because I have a ledge with his palm in
my my
bicep you see Okay then if I lost the
curvature in his arm let's say that's
what this hand is for I just brought it
back
okay here's that straight arm right if I
pass it over as you see often then they
stand up so the way I keep the pressure
on the shoulders is by
Rolling
okay then her elbows don't have her
elbow on the feet side of your Center
Line because then you have to use all of
your torquing
muscles okay be ex have
extension I have to put her elbow on the
front side of my Center Line see that
and now I can just
bow okay you guys got that
okay the line
again there's the
finger put it in the
P get to the
back should be going around to right
yeah you UK goes around n right okay so
I I don't sit here right go here here
I'm I'm going around her
okay oh she's going to go around
me see how I
doing it's it's a for UK
right
the if I turn to my left I leave my
right knee in the spot and my left
foot
try
so
no leave your right knee on a dime it's
on a dime don't let anyone get it and
leave your left foot on the D come
up leave that
there put your foot out for your BS
straight out from your leg there you go
now watch wind
back okay so stays there St
there up
turn you want to go the other way you
leave the left knee where it is and the
right foot where it is okay
St put your foot
down so now you start using this foot
let's turn with our pinning the dime
with our right KN use this foot to push
you watch watch what I do watch two ways
it's a passive turn right I turn like
this then this fo's going to push
me
pushing
try push it that foot that's it bring
your foot out again there you go there's
your face and try
both uh the front foot
foot because that foot's going to take
you into the Ido Tenon
right so so this foot's pushing pushing
so you can drive back
boom okay uh you have to you don't want
to just hurt someone's wrist okay you're
not going I got you
okay okay there has to be a tactical
reason for it other than it hurt him and
that points for me okay you're you're
not out to hurt him and it may not hurt
him you're out to control his body and
in this case you're out to pin his body
so your your reason for pinning should
be to uh control his body and your
reason for controling his body should be
to pin him so I use one to cause the
other so I throw him in the p and he
goes down from there think like stages
how do I get someone down well I'm going
to get him down in
stages
okay I seeing too much of I got you haha
then you came around like that okay and
you're there's no connection between the
Nel pin and the final solution so this
is I got a guy who's upright I'm going
to lower him so that I can do that
easier okay because we want to
F all the way back up up up because this
is not going to
work you see that will not work cuz he's
too strong there he's he's as equal as I
am our posture but now I start to
compromise
his then this work now okay so start
putting it
together and don't
go got you use this to throw him into
that you guys see that again
side boom use this boom to throw him
into that okay taking the chem the first
thing is I can't be freaking out over
the pain that's coming in my way okay I
must have a calm spirit so I'm accepting
of what's going to happen I'm not
judging it I'm not avoiding it he
goes my feet are up don't be have this
dead Corps body mine feet are up I'm I'm
aware
I let the tension out before I get
up I don't use that arm to pop pop me
up and I let go of that W
[Music]
entirely
now my face is
stoic
I move Wherever not it he's telling me
to move with his
energy I don't have to
work I have to
accept
okay
[Music]
right
rush them high
right out don't hold don't try and turn
this
okay pin it to you okay and now turn
your
body and now you're on the thumb side of
of this arm anchor your
elbows don't bring this stretch up like
that remember I'm not pinning you now
your your body should be
dropping
boom pin turn now you're on the thumb
side anchor your elbows and your body
does
that don't pick it
up
drop okay here we
go I turn turn turn
turn
and your skirt has to
be huge you can't
be okay your sht has to be
out you have to have a huge body
mind okay your
pins have you so focused on in a weird
way on the detail of the
pin and so it's capturing your mind and
you end up having a small technique you
know it's it's air is
small and the odd part is that when you
focus in on those little details like
that and you get that small air to it
you actually lose
details so you're so preoccupied with
the details that you actually don't have
many details in your Technique at the
same time your fighting spirit is
Tiny okay uh versus you know I have all
the details and I'm I kind of have this
broad Larger than Life aspect here and
you you get a sense of that because for
some reason the UK uh is moving way
more than is explainable at first
glance um in other words when you have
this larger Spirit but we can't just
seems to move more to have been moved
more we have this tiny spirit that UK
barely
moves and I'm not telling you to have
actual physical big movements I'm
telling you to have a a spiritual
largess to your
Technique and to have that spiritual
largess you can't be fettered by over
focusing on one detail that in fact is
going to make you lose another detail
and another detail and another detail so
whether it's a matter of
familiarity I have to know this
technique more I have to practice it
more so I don't feel pressured to over
focus and be FedEd with one particular
detail or whether it's a matter of just
the this this the maturity level of my
spirit in that I tend to focus on one
thing and lose the big
whatever the case through training you
have to address that so that you have
this larger fighting spirit so that UK
is actually
being uh you know
affecting